literally season one if you had to
describe it in one sentence it was hot
nasty
stinky dirty
and bloody technically that's not a
sentence i think those are the five
words that kripke used to sell the show
it was those five words and then
superheroes
hey gq i'm chase crawford i play the
deep on the boys hi i'm karen fukuhara i
play kimiko i'm anthony starr i play
homeland hey i'm jensen ackles i play
soldier boy i'm laz alonso
and i play mother's milk on amazon prime
series the boys
these
are some of our biggest moments here
i thought it was hilarious because we
didn't see your part of the whale right
we just shot ours and then no right i
couldn't even see yeah they're like just
get up on the whale and just okay the
boat's coming you know and it was in the
blowhole
we had a blast shooting that whole
sequence i think it was three four days
it was you guys were bloody i mean
inside the guts of it right yeah yeah
yeah right yeah before the uh blood and
guts
yeah i mean carl was driving that boat
like a madman and he was enjoying it
yeah the director of that episode is an
ex-stunt man that's steve steve yes yes
steve so he literally had a helicopter
that he was in and so we were shooting
like miami vice shots the whole day we
spent on the lake from like early that
morning to evening carl drove the boat
and then steve's up on a helicopter just
like taking like sweeping shots all over
they're like right in front of us the
helicopter's going backwards and he's
like zooming over our heads and you know
we're like you know cracking in tubs and
jack was sitting in the very front of
the boat
we had a safe word
it was carl carl carl carpenter
but the thing is is he's in front of us
so we can't hit because he's screaming
forward and we're behind him we got the
motor going like everybody's like into
it and then when we stop jack turns
around
and looks like he has no blood in his
face yeah blue he's blue
lips are blue tongue is blue
everything on him
except his butt which is bright red
right right
oh he got a red ass and yeah
jack didn't make it to the end of that
day they had to come get him out we had
to send the boat out to come get him
oh yeah and then the boats
shake yeah we were gonna go one more
take one more take and then they said oh
there's a hole in the boat well really
when i told them there was a hole it was
coming in through the through the motor
it was a nutty day it was a nutty day
yes
supposed to float yeah if it's sinking
something's wrong
whoa
hey look you're gorgeous i'm not i'm not
talking about sex just a little bit of
pull smoking it's just a question of how
bad you want to be in the seven
after i was cast or you know they're
like okay we want to do this scene from
the comics and this specific shot
we had a long time to rehearse and talk
about it and all the nuances of it and
stuff like that what
i mean you said you had a crush on me i
figured that you know he sees nothing
wrong with it it's just something he's
entitled to almost like as [ __ ] up as
it is like oh this is what we do to the
rookies or whatever like he's almost
surprised when it doesn't work out the
way
you know it's sort of
plain which is really [ __ ] up
no what so they could tell the world
that we left the rest of them to [ __ ]
die come on you stay the [ __ ] back on
our laser you god damn it i'll laser
every [ __ ] one of you
let's go the whole plane the sequence
was filmed in
obviously in a plane there's you can
rent film-worthy planes which are
basically gutted except for the seats
and you can move around in them and get
cameras in there and it was a funny day
because dom she was just traumatized the
entire day and i i just found the whole
thing hysterically funny watching these
stunt guys get sucked out of plane doors
and it's very on-brand it was yeah it
was like we had such a different
experience because i was just i i've
always found the dark stuff in this show
laced with comedy which i think is that
sweet spot that we that the show lives
in where you know it's it's accessible
because there's always this humor are
you going to save us oh sweetheart of
course i'm going to save you you betcha
but plural dom had to um go through that
day like you know welling up and getting
emotional and so we had very different
experiences but it was it was definitely
a fun day at work of course the cherry
on top was watching um
chase have a dolphin fly through the
windscreen at the end of the day that's
great it all dovetailed together lovely
next stop the atlantic ocean
that's right
that's right
i was shooting the dolphin scene in in a
big warehouse and then you know they're
shaking the thing and spritzing the
dolphin down and anthony's in like the
massive airplane across the way we were
shooting those here on the same day it
was just a very harrowing intense you
know action sequence in me like
shut the [ __ ] up if i just touch it when
you shut up
it was so funny it was really funny
acting with that prosthetic dolphin but
you saw it was the same day right right
yeah i just walked over and just sat
watching and laughing yeah yeah i mean
you're like greenpeace's worst nightmare
you like you take out dolphins season
two it's a whale it's like what next
manatee
your heads keep coming
[Music]
really season one was probably the
dirtiest
season for the boys any dungeness hot no
ac
dirty like we chased her through real
subway tunnels the reason why we were
able to use the subway was because we
had to use the abandoned tracks two
stories under the regular tracks and
there were no elevators and we had to
shoot overnights when the subway was
closed there were rats
there were mice and rats on the trains
and then i had to be barefoot you had to
be barefoot because your fake feet they
gave a fake prosthetic feet that didn't
work they'd never work and she had yeah
it was nuts it was nuts i guess she's uh
camiko's had a glow up since then yeah
yes luckily
i said
later
oh my god
so the day after he shot that scene i
remember going in the makeup trailer and
his gills his whole chest plate and
gills
were laying in the makeup trailer and my
dumb ass
decided to touch the gills they're
beautiful man and it moves they're
beautiful i literally ended up on the
other side of the makeup trailer and my
hand was dripping white like clear goo
it's very lubricated mystery goop very
slippery and the gills moved by them
they were like yeah they they moved on
their own yeah they're truly disgusting
and you'll never forget it they made
like a replica of my chest so in season
one when i did d passes come up and
she can you know oh you're like getting
your [ __ ] finger
a rep because my chest is on my own
chest and they're like pumping hand
pumps to make the move and it was it was
a lot that day it was like yeah it was a
lot
eagle hey
in here open up
bro we gotta talk kripke was actually
like we're gonna get helen mirren to
voice the gills you know he's
shooting for the moon can you imagine
you're joking but yeah gotta go to i
gotta go
lay down
maybe but no i think he's joking until
he's not though
uh
yeah the milk thing has really taken
normal life of its own it started with
eric he wrote it into the the first
scene when i was i found some leftover
still well juice in the freezer
mummy juice
laser it warm and then colby interrupts
she walks in and it was like one of
those moments where i was like oh we
just got to go for it and be like
[Music]
as soon as we were doing it it was like
oh [ __ ] we gotta we gotta keep this
going so email [ __ ] buddy that was so
much fun it was so funny i think we got
to do more and he's like i'm way ahead
of you man i've seen the dailies and you
get ready to drink milk because like
okay
yep
yeah the dairy marketing board loves it
it just became this little motif and
it's really demented which actually in a
weird way opened a lot of doors into the
character and into how weird we could go
and then we've really exploited that
entirely
in season three season three it doesn't
not factor in
[Music]
i thought it was really cool that we
went through her backstory in season two
and i had the best time
working with abraham who plays kenji
there was sort of this uh chemistry uh
because we had this friendship offset
isn't that your own language as well
what do you call it again we call it ksl
ksl so instead of asl ksl sign language
and it's 100
only spoken by karen fukara it's a
hundred percent gibberish yeah yeah it's
we have a dictionary so it's uh you do
yeah yeah we do you should start selling
it maybe you can make a quick 20 bucks
mate
those were some hard scenes to shoot i
think the
stunt coordinators on the show are
amazing and they allow for a lot of
rehearsal time so it's not just you know
you show up the day before and then you
learn it especially for season three um
john was all about prep for each of the
fights i had maybe sometimes a month to
go in and learn it all and get it in my
muscle memory it's how you make a safe
set
dad please
please don't make me jump
you call me dad
well i mean i didn't actually push a
child off a roof let's be clear
um because i actually did get some
messages and twitter going what's wrong
he's an awesome little kid so he's great
he's fun and then we did it actually on
like it's about two foot high just threw
him off
off the edge of a two-foot thing into a
something i i can't fly i'll just fall
right off of him hey hey buddy you're
gonna love it i promise
nothing like you i can't fly you can i
promise you can it didn't really
translate what it was gonna look like
you did it when we were doing it because
i that most of the things i do it's
always there's never much practical it's
like lasering the plane is like just
green around you with a couple of tennis
balls then i see it now oh that looks
great and that was the case with this it
didn't really it didn't compute so it
was just like all right we've done that
can i go and have a lunch now yep and
then i saw it
when it was finally done and just burst
out laughing and the thing that really
made it for me was his little squeal as
he comes as he flies off
and that little ah comes out
and i like oh god i was crying laughing
at that i thought it was hysterical it's
also the casualness in which homeland is
like
right like
this is the disappointment after that
so it's not a great parent
stormfront was a racist
cold-hearted [ __ ]
so it felt good that kimiko got to uh
get a little bit of revenge at the end
and it was even better that it was not
just kimiko but with all the other girls
as well
yeah we had a really great time shooting
that action sequence i would not say the
same for aya
she had she had a hard time it kind of
tied it all together full circle moment
for kimiko at least and it was real
hand-to-hand combat which i loved uh not
all super powers and so um it was fun to
do that whole shoot was really really
cold though it was starting to i think
it was november in toronto and
we were still wearing our i guess summer
clothing but we had to continuously
shoot so
it was very very cold uh
we remember like wearing all the canada
goose in between takes and everything
and warming up
[Music]
instagram loved it
it was laza's first favorite day yeah
i've noticed that
some of my fellow cast members were
taking
sneaky shots unbeknownst to me
while i was rehearsing
we had to but you thought carl was
pulling a prank on you yes um and he he
was explaining to laz what happens in
the script and um he didn't believe it
he comes up to everyone he came up to me
and he was like karen is he [ __ ] with
me like
it actually happened i was like laz have
you read this it's in there
it wasn't in the first
draft in the first draft my character
just sees him on the cctv screen and he
just goes oh man brother gotta love
sausage that's good god damn
brother's gotta love sausage and then by
like draft 11 it's strangling me
and so then i go to karen who's one of
my confidants on set and she's like yeah
it's really happening and i'm like oh
you too you're in on it with him even
like the makeup girls everybody's like
laughing and like giggling and i'm like
you guys that's really happening
they're like you might want to
ask for a new copy of the script i go to
my trailer and i'm like
you know it was a crazy week we shot
that at a real abandoned mental hospital
in this area called london which was
about two three hours away so we had to
sleep out there and live out there for
for about a week that's all we did was
you know 13 hours a day we were in this
abandoned mental facility that certain
parts of it was quote unquote haunted
according to certain people by the time
we got to that that shot we were already
indoctrinated like we were there so we
were in the zone and we just went for it
what's that
that's his [ __ ] dick
don't be so close-minded do you guys
ever sit when we're doing things like
this and and listen and then think well
i could have done anything else with my
life and then talk about stuff like that
i could have been a lawyer
could have done anything i was just
sitting there there listening to that
story going wow that's insane what we're
doing
we're sitting here talking about a man
wrestling a prosthetic penis
i love it i love it everyone needs a day
job right